Boom,
and we're live.
Dude.
You survive.
What's up buddy?
Jorge.
He survived the Joey Diaz experience.
You know,
I got,
I got a um,
I got uh,
uh,
attacks from Tom.
Tom.
Tom,
right?
Yeah.
I said because he asked me,
we were backstage about to go onstage at
the main room and he's like,
I want you to do my podcast,
blah blah blah.
And I'm like,
awesome.
And then we were texting just about my
schedule with him and then he's.
And then I'm like,
okay,
I'm going to go see Joey Diaz de da.
And he's like,
dude,
fucking gummy bears.
Watch out.
And I'm like,
what are you talking about?
I didn't like,
I didn't understand what he was talking
about.
Like I didn't,
you know what I mean?
I didn't,
I honestly didn't like,
I was like,
whatever,
I don't what you're talking about.
And then once I got there,
you know,
I smoke weed sometimes,
I don't smoke all the time but I like to
smoke weed sometimes,
but the,
but as far as the edibles,
I like Dean Gelber is like given me some
pot stuff.
But like cookies and shit,
but then like he was eating these gummy
bears and they're in,
in a bag and I was like,
going,
fuck,
okay.
And he gave me just like,
uh,
he gave me just like an ear or some shit
and that was it.
And then I was just like talking to him
and then like literally I couldn't talk
anymore.
I couldn't talk part of it right at a
half a one I had to leave.
He's got some that are like 500
milligrams,
which is just insane.
So you probably had half of that,
which is like 250,
which is fucking insane.
That's an insane amount of weed.
But
Gee,
I had.
But I had done mushrooms once before
when I was younger and it felt like
that.
Yeah,
well that's the risk of repeating myself
over and over again,
which I do all the time.
But when you eat marijuana,
it's processed by your liver and it
produces something called 11 hydroxy
metabolite.
It's a totally different psychoactive
substance sets,
four to five times more psychoactive
than thc.
So that's why it hits you like that.
And that's why people think they got
dosed because when you smoke pot that
the,
it's not psychoactive,
but when you eat it,
it's processed by your liver.
It's something called a one pass.
And that's how it produces that.
Yeah.
And I can't believe he let me drive
home.
Like,
seriously.
I mean I could like.
Because when I was driving home I was
like,
dude,
I got to go.
Like I stopped that guy,
can't answer your questions.
And then I said let's,
I have to go.
And I left and I drove out and he like,
he let me drive.
Like
you got to understand Joey Diaz found
his mother dead on the kitchen floor
when he was on acid when he was 13.
He would let you fly a fucking plane on
those things.
He doesn't give a shit.
He's just like,
you'll figure it out.
Cock sucker.
Anyways.
So when did it hit you?
Like he did a podcast,
like how,
how different do I have?
Fifteen minutes into it and I couldn't
speak.
I had to stop.
I couldn't speak.
Just released the podcast.
I don't know.
I think he did the audio but not the
video.
Oh,
I told them not to do it.
Video.
I couldn't answer any questions,
but wouldn't that be funny?
Yeah,
I guess.
I don't know.
I would like to see myself that fucked
up where I can't even talk.
Those,
uh,
those edibles are fucking terrifying.
Terrifying.
I'm like,
they were like,
you know,
skittles or some shit.
He's a different type of human.
Well,
there's a lot of those people now
because edibles and marijuana has been
legal for so long.
There's so many medical patients in
California that you get these people
that have insane tolerances and they're
just doing dabs and eaten cookies and
just like Jesus,
just like they go down
unit the whole marijuana movement and
that whole thing is so much different.
Different when,
when I was growing up,
you know,
when I grew up,
we still like smoke it too.
We'd go to the beach and we put a towel
over us.
We'd hide it now.
Like,
like last night I was at the,
uh,
the funny or die party and it was a,
it was the 10th anniversary and I was
just walking around,
just smells like weed everywhere.
It's just very normal now.
Like,
you know,
that,
I don't know,
that's just the way I think it's good
because it's just like drinking is
normally by the bar,
the comedy store,
you see a bunch of people having a
couple of drinks is wrong with that.
It's all good,
but thanks for having me.
My pleasure.
Yeah.
I'll tell you this,
this,
uh,
impression.
You're dealing with this White House
character.
What's his name again?
Uh,
Steven Miller.
Yeah.
That's,
first of all,
everyone's doing Sean Spicer.
They weren't until he got fired or they
did go is,
it's a scaramucci and Sean's.
Yeah.
Melissa Mccarthy Doing Sean Spicer
killed it.
Yeah.
It's hilarious.
It's funny.
Trump thought that it made him look weak
that a woman was doing an impression of
would,
should go and do an impression and trump
now because of that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
I mean,
I don't know.
I think that,
you know,
I did a special,
what was it like,
I think it was like 2012 for showtime
called politics where I went to DC and I
did stand up in DC and I interviewed all
Paul.
I love politicians.
Like that's all I watch when I come home
at night.
All I watch is CNN,
msn,
and Fox just because that's it.
Because I'm in shock and I can't believe
it.
No,
I just go back and forth that there's so
many fucked up things that are going on
the world.
The whole North Korea thing is insane.
It's scary.
It's fucking insane.
But what's
Gary is that Donald trump is saying shit
like fire and fury that the world has
never known.
Like Jesus Dude,
like this isn't a movie.
This is real life.
Yeah,
but I mean this North Korean guys
fucking nuts.
Fucking nuts.
It's like,
it's like,
dude,
stop shooting fucking missiles in the
fucking.
This isn't like a playpen thing.
He just kept shooting missiles in the
ocean all the time.
Like it's like he's like a kid or some
shit and kid.
It's just,
I don't know,
it's just a,
well I think Guam is only like 2000
miles away from North Korea or something
like real close.
So they're talking about him possibly
bombing Guam and that's what they're
saying now.
And I know I've been watching,
but it isn't a death sentence.
I mean if,
if we decided to attack North Korea,
it would be a death sentence to them.
And then also I heard,
because I know,
I know Dennis Rodman.
Dennis,
do you,
did you talk to him when he went over
there?
I know like,
I don't want to get too too into it,
but I know that he goes over there a
lot.
Yeah,
he meets with Kim Jones,
Aau basketball or something.
They just fucking get drunk and I don't
know,
they go on jet skis or some shit.
Like he,
like,
he like,
uh,
um,
he likes Dennis Rodman so it brings them
out.
But from what I heard is that Kim Jong
Goon really loves Donald Trump.
Like,
you know what I mean?
Like his American,
he loves America,
but he's kind of acting like he doesn't
love America.
Like he loves the American way.
Look at that picture.
Yeah.
So my point is,
is I think I really think that if Donald
Trump went over there to meet with the
guy,
I think that would appease him and show
him the fuck out.
I think that's just my opinion.
Maybe you should be like a liaison.
Yeah.
See,
there you go.
But he gets,
he gets uh,
you know,
he goes over there and hangs out with
them because they.
Kim Jong Un kid loves,
loves,
loves American.
Yeah.
He loves America.
And that's Kinda like a weird,
you know,
there's,
there's no,
um,
what's the word?
There's no,
uh,
no kind of modification.
Communication.
They're not communicating right.
You know.
Well there's language barrier obviously,
but it's neat.
Young.
Isn't Kim Jong Goon?
Like in his thirties.
How old is he?
Yeah,
he's pretty young.
It's mean.
Imagine running a military dictatorship
in your thirties and he's already
murdered.
A gang of people are already in.
The thing that's so crazy about the
whole thing is that like you think of
Isis and you think of that whole,
you know how those people like,
they don't care to die and they don't
care if they're going to die and I think
that he's trained his people.
All the CBC,
all it's on CNN.
You this marching soldiers.
I think those guys are ready to die.
Well,
if you lived in a shit hole like North
Korea where everyday you're under the
oppressive of a military dictatorship,
maybe you'd be ready to die to you.
Like it's either escape to South Korea
or die.
Yeah.
I,
I think what had happened is I think
trump should hire Dennis Rodman and like
put like a tracking device on them and
their jet skiing out in fucking the
ocean drinking and shit.
And the seal team six comes in and
fucking takes Kim Jong Buen flies into
America,
gives all the North Korean internet and
like sets them free.
No,
this is like a movie dude.
Don't you get it?
Was Stephen Baldwin?
No,
but I that.
I just think that there's probably a way
to,
to chill everything.
The probably is a,
which everything out.
This is not the way like launching test
missiles and saying fire and fury and
all that shit.
It's not,
not chilling anything out,
but you know,
I don't understand what the conflict is
about in the first place.
I'm not exactly sure what everybody's
angry.
I think because they think that we're
going to bomb them and we're going to
bomb them like that.
We did years ago,
right.
They.
Well,
North Korea.
No,
Hiroshima was Japan.
The Asians,
I think.
I don't know the details,
so it's part of the world,
but that's cool.
That'll be super psyched.
Conflate the two of them.
Yeah.
No,
it's um,
I mean we did horrible things during the
Korean War to the North Koreans.
I mean that's literally the cause of all
of this.
All the anger and all the,
you know,
but that's when North Korea and South
Korea were split and North Korea went
communists and you know,
it's a,
it's all a byproduct of that.
You know,
there's,
you could read about it and actually
there's a really good book called dear
reader from Michael Malice.
He's a guy who was on my podcast and the
history of that part of the world is
really fucked up,
but it's interesting because you have
North Korea and then below you have
South Korea,
you have a thriving economy,
amazing electronic Samsung.
They make all kinds of great shit over
there.
And his boss,
probably plastic surgery,
Medica,
Eh,
and then North Korea is just right next
door to them.
Terrible dictatorship.
That's fucked up man.
Well no president has been able to deal
with it,
so yeah,
probably won't be able to mean.
How do you resolve that?
One of the things that my mouse was
telling me that makes it so fucked up is
that everybody has to rat on everybody
else.
Like say if you and I were working
together,
we would have to go somewhere and tell
someone what each one of us did wrong
during the day.
Like maybe you didn't try hard enough
when somebody died or maybe you weren't
excited enough,
but something good happened.
He didn't cheer loud enough and they'll,
they'll rat you out for that and then
you know,
you have to be accountable and then so
they have like a culture of rats.
Everybody's ratting everybody out.
That
sounds fun.
We don't realize how lucky we are,
you know,
to live in America would do.
It's one of the reasons why people
complained so much about stuff because
we're so soft.
Any slight little thing that's wrong.
You ever been to prison before?
No,
never.
Well,
I went to Alcatraz,
but just to visit as a uh,
never been arrested.
I always think like spending time in
prison would make you appreciate just
the simple things because you always
see,
you always see like,
you know,
people that are incarcerated,
they get out and they like see the
sunlight and they're like,
oh my God,
this is fucking awesome.
And part of me is like,
I think everyone should go to prison for
like a month just to kind of get that,
get their normal freedoms taken away
from them.
You know,
I'm actually doing a benefit and I was
going to ask you if you want to do.
I don't know if you're in town at the
comedy store for the innocence project.
Are you familiar with them?
Yeah,
I am.
I'm doing it.
I'm doing it on August 27th.
At least people that are incarcerated.
Innocent.
Yeah.
So if you want to do it,
I got it.
Everyone's doing it already.
That's August 27th and it's for,
you know,
Barry Scheck and that whole team of
people that,
that exonerate,
you know,
people that go to prison for crimes they
didn't commit,
you know,
that whole thing,
right?
Yeah.
Well I'm flying in from DC.
Oh,
that's on Sunday.
Yeah,
yeah,
I could do that.
That'd be great.
Yeah,
I'll do it.
that'd be great.
I got a great lineup.
I got um,
everyone's on it already,
but I was going to ask you.
I'm sure he'd be into that.
That'd be seen the night before.
Oh,
cool.
I'm flying in trouble yet,
so I want to raise money for them.
Yeah,
because I want to give.
I want to give money back to these guys
because when they got into jail they
don't have anything and they're not
given anything given like a dollar,
you know what I mean?
I know.
And then they have to somehow or another
figure out how to sue to get some
compensation for the fact they were
wrongly in prison.
But how'd you like to be in prison for
20 years knowing you had nothing to do
with it and there's people that are in
prison for killing your mom and stuff
like that.
Imagine someone kills your mom.
It's not you.
And then you get arrested and go to jail
for it.
Yeah.
No,
it's terrible.
But the fruit person at the end of the
bar is pretty cool.
You gonna eat here just for a year.
Okay.
Did you see blood sugar's so low.
You're like,
I can't,
I can't wait 15 minutes.
No.
But did you see the fruit man at the
corner?
No,
I did not.
There's a fruit snack,
a little Mexican fruit.
Guys,
chop the fruit.
Don't tell ice.
Sorry.
Yeah,
we'll pull that guy across the border.
Bring them back.
Yeah.
So,
um,
how did you,
what was the thought process behind
doing an impression of this dude?
It's gone viral.
It's over a million hits now,
right?
Yeah.
It's like at a million seven around
that.
Yeah.
And it's,
uh,
it's caught on.
It's just,
I don't know.
You've been doing this,
you've been doing this a long time.
We did the makeup for you.
How did they do it?
A Guy,
uh,
um,
you know,
the business statue of Liberty facts.
Yeah.
You just do these things and certain
things catch on.
Certain things don't get John and in
this thing caught on.
So I don't know,
I was pretty stoked.
Is that him back in the day?
That's him now.
He doesn't look like that now though.
He's way more bold than that.
No.
Yeah,
he's um,
um,
but yeah,
no,
it was cool.
It was a,
I,
I've done stuff with them before.
I actually did a,
an anthony wiener sketch to,
I don't know if you saw that one.
Yeah,
it's pretty cool.
I did that when I play Anthony Wiener.
I did that about four or five,
six months ago.
And then this thing came up,
they just hit me up,
then,
you know,
I do stuff for funny or die sometimes
and in this thing caught on and it went
everywhere and I was on CNN and in,
in,
uh,
you know,
every,
even political,
a political,
um,
sites picked it up the hill and all
these different places picked it up.
So I don't know,
I just did it.
And they know what I mean.
Yeah.
Just do shit.
And like,
you don't know what the fuck.
So it was.
Yeah,
it was funny.
I saw the weird thing too.
Wiener I think is a comic.
He's hilarious.
I think he's a comic.
He just doesn't.
He doesn't know it.
I mean,
he's still committed to being the.
he tried to be the mayor and he can't
eat.
If it wasn't the latest scandal,
he would've come close a hundred
percent.
Yeah.
And did you see his,
uh,
his documentary?
Yes.
Grazing spoke.
It's amazing.
It's so fucked up.
So you see I'm lasting.
OKC didn't give him any eating given any
edible.
I'm not going to give at this point in
the Joe Diaz.
I was like,
dude,
I got to go.
He kept asking me questions.
I couldn't answer anything.
No,
I wasn't going to do is to imagine if
everybody that I know do that too.
Every time cigarette to the two I did
two red bed.
Doesn't tell anyone,
but I've heard everyone kind of can't
handle it.
Most people.
Well,
the numbers of Joey puts up.
No very few humans can handle it,
you know?
But don't you think back to Anthony
Wiener?
I think that guy should have been a
comic.
Like he's got this idea about what's
good and what's bad,
but he's also a pervert under like the
guise of comic Yo.
He's a great speaker.
He's hilarious.
He obviously loves posting.
Honestly was supposed to.
I mean he's,
he's a fucking character.
I mean,
I just think that he's trapped in that
suppressed world of being a politician
where he obviously doesn't fit those
standards,
those standards of behavior that they
demand of you that are all bullshit
anyway,
but he's too fucked up.
He's too crazy.
I think the more fucked up things that
people find out about the politicians,
the more popular they become.
Some of them I mean,
right?
Yeah,
I mean in a way clean about it.
If he could come clean about all of it
until like the,
but still in the day of trump things way
different.
Right?
Because trump got elected a month after
that,
grabbed them by the pussy thing came
out.
Everybody thought that was gonna sink as
both like that's it.
And he still wins.
So I think the world is different,
but I don't think wiener has the
constitution that trump has trump say
what you want about them,
but the motherfucker as teflon for skin
things just saying bounce right off.
Doesn't give a shit.
Just like.
Yeah.
Insane.
I,
um,
I know him from back in the day.
Yeah.
I mean you have to understand I've been
doing this.
How long have you been doing it?
Thirty years.
Twenty nine?
Yeah.
So I've been doing it 30 years.
When did you come to the store with ir?
Ninety four.
Ninety four?
Yeah.
So you were there.
Is that when he came to the store?
Yeah,
94.
Ninety four.
I became a paid regular.
Wow.
Yeah.
So I was um,
I was doing spring break for
MTV.
When was it?
It was like 89,
90,
91,
92.
And it was,
you know,
obviously the biggest thing in the world
because it was live and there's hundreds
of thousands of jobs.
I did spring break in $2,000
for an MTV.
Okay.
Right.
When it was sort of like,
oh,
well,
yeah.
And um,
and we did it and it was,
I'm Hawaiian tropics or the biggest
thing in the world.
All the girls and Fabio was there and
Jon Lovitz was there.
Vince Neil was there,
Kennison was there.
Rodney Dangerfield was there and Donald
trump was there.
And because Donald trump used to go to
the Hawaiian Hawaiian tropic parties
that Ron Rice used to throw after the
spring break things.
And Donald Trump was,
I knew him back then.
So.
And then I saw him probably about a
couple times at the playboy mansion.
The last time I saw him at the playboy
mansion I think was about four years ago
and he was just there just hanging out,
just hanging like Bill Maher,
you know what I mean?
Just fucking,
just fucking hanging.
It was,
it was actually in the afternoon and I
think it was like a Sunday fun day thing
or it was like some like Easter egg
night day or some shit.
And he was just buzzing around and in
this suit and just talking to girls and,
and um,
yeah,
him and Oj,
you know.
Oh,
LJ,
Lj will be out to.
I know it was bizarre.
So what,
what does Donald Trump like when you're
hanging around with them?
He just likes vagina,
you know what I mean?
Like he just like us,
you know,
like,
he's looking at those babies are,
you know,
it was always like that.
I mean that's why anyone go to the
playboy mansion because they liked
vagina and we were lucky to get into the
playboy mansion.
We were very fortunate,
you know what I mean,
to get in there.
And um,
but it was so,
you know,
and I was actually talking to Kellyanne
conway about um,
right before trump got elected on email
and I was supposed to have dinner with
her and some of her friends,
but I had to go do some shows in west
palm at the Improv,
so I had to cancel out to talk to
Kellyanne Conway about,
just to be there.
Of course,
have a weird.
We've been a hilarious.
I wanted to,
you know what I mean?
For sure.
But she was cool.
We run it.
I have her email ever information that
stuff.
Yeah.
You should get her on your show.
You put her on your show.
Oh yeah,
I would definitely talk to her.
Does it feel weird though to be
connected to them now?
What happened?
Eventually ends.
Yeah,
once,
yeah.
Once she got.
Once they got in and I started to see
all that stuff that was going on,
I kind of like backed off and I was
like,
hmm.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I didn't want to really be,
you know,
but I want to be the vagina coordinator
for him.
That was like hooks it up.
Yeah.
That gets some vaginal.
Can't be public about that.
Can't talk about it.
So if we talk about you gonna fuck it up
for him.
Oh,
that's true right now.
You're fucking it up for them just a bit
folks.
Yeah,
we're just nail Polish.
But how great would that be?
The idea is that he's got the trump
plane,
you know the trump plane.
It's sitting there.
It was.
Where is it sitting somewhere,
right?
Where is that?
It's got to be sitting in like on a
tarmac somewhere.
So I want him to let me borrow it so I
can pick up vagina from in the Midwest.
The Midwest is the move.
Well you had the people that voted for
him.
They're happy for him.
Yeah.
That have the flyover states bring some,
you know,
one tooth wanders,
bringing,
bringing them to the da because dude,
he hasn't gotten anything.
Think about it,
but he's been like cutoff.
Strange hundred percent.
Do you think?
So there's like a basement that they
have in the White House.
There's no way he's getting vagina,
but.
So none of them do you think?
None of the presidents with modern
presidents like I guess like Bush on,
right Bush,
Obama,
now trump.
There's no way they can write.
I don't think so.
Clinton kind of fucked it up for
everybody.
Know who is it?
Linda TRIPP said the lady who ran it,
that Monica Lewinsky girl out of poor
girl,
I feel more bad for her than anybody.
Like she,
she.
There was some article about her where
she said the shame sticks to you,
like tar.
Imagine poor girl,
which is 20 years old at this point.
I guess she's got it right.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
But so what does trump like those,
you a good guy to talk to?
Like what is he like?
Obviously he hadn't,
he didn't want to run for president
back.
Yeah.
I think he had been wanting to.
I mean if you look at clips now you see
a lot of clips where he was,
where they interview them and now about
like you find clips in the nineties
where they always say,
who is it?
The guy from?
Um,
I forgot that one.
Sean Msn,
but tim something.
I Dunno,
he died.
But um,
he says,
well,
if you were president that uh,
oh yeah,
meet the press.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Actually I was watching that today where
he was talking about North Korea.
It was a little clip where he's talking
about North Korea for your 19,
99.
And I never really engaged in like heavy
conversation with him.
It was always kind of just,
you know,
we smiled at each other.
It was just that,
you know,
so I never like went out to dinner with
them or anything.
But yeah,
I was supposed to do celebrity
apprentice.
They asked me to do celebrity apprentice
when they had the second integration of
fear factor when fear factor came back
and like,
what is it,
2011 or 12 or whatever it was.
And um,
I just was like,
I don't want to do it.
I just want,
I don't want to be in New York for three
months.
I don't want to work on this show.
It just seems kind of gross.
And now that I think about it,
Mike is probably a good move because
like,
what if I did it and I'm like got in an
argument with,
with him,
like,
what if he hated me?
Right now I have this fucking feud like
rosie does because Rosie O'donnell,
it seems like it consumes her like her
fucking twitter feed.
Is it still?
Oh my God,
that's all.
She's always tweeting about trump being
piece of shit and a loser.
And He tweets about her.
That's hilarious.
They're grown people.
Yeah.
More right there.
Look at that.
Oh Donald looking bad honey.
Wow.
Take time to take care of you.
It's only Wednesday golf sweetie.
Golf.
That's hilarious.
Oh my God.
How can she say anything about anybody
looking bad?
That's what's even more dumb.
Shit.
She's crazy.
I don't know.
It's just like feuds like that.
They're not healthy.
They consume you.
Not Good.
I'm not good at all.
So you're going to continue doing this
dude,
what's his name again?
Steven Miller.
Um,
I guess if he keeps messing up and they
want me to do it.
Yeah.
You could do a whole bunch of things
with Tim.
Right.
And him explaining things to different
people.
I think it's more if he messes up.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
I think it's more if he goes on,
you know,
I just wanted them to get back on that
press stage because once he's on there,
then they start,
you know what I mean?
And that's when he,
that's when he becomes,
you know,
was weird as is.
When George Bush was president,
you know,
uh,
I was doing some shows in DC and me and
Dean Gilbert,
we went to a,
we went to the White House and we
actually went into that room,
the pressroom and it's actually like
fucking small.
It's pretty little.
Have you been in it?
No,
but I've seen it on TV when they show up
from the back of the room.
Yeah.
But it's,
it's almost like this big.
It's pretty small.
I was like,
whoa.
You know what I mean?
It's weird.
It was to be grand.
Yeah.
But the,
the White House,
did he,
have you been to the White House before?
No,
just the tourists walk there.
I know.
It's fucking weird.
I'm sure it's so weird.
You know what's weird is how close it is
to this street.
It goes by it,
uh,
drove by.
But,
but that was back when people had
muskets,
you know,
like they really couldn't.
When they built that stupid fucking
thing,
they didn't give them enough space.
If somebody just pulled up at a high
powered rifle,
it's right there.
It's just weird that people like you
watch house of cards.
It's a great show,
but it's so,
it's weird because they're engaging in
all sorts of illicit activity and
there's windows everywhere.
It's probably unrealistic but,
but um,
how many people have lived in that
fucking house?
That's what's even weirder.
You know,
45 different presidents all live in this
one spot.
I know,
it's crazy.
I mean they have to be saying that shit
to each other.
I mean,
Bill Clinton or trump's got to be
saying,
there it is.
Trump started saying like,
this is the place that Bill Clinton got
blown.
This is the area.
Look how close it is.
Let go look in the left side.
And the right side,
look how close it is to the street.
I guarantee you I can hit that with a,
with an arrow.
You're going to DC,
right?
Yeah.
And you've done there August 27th.
Do you like dc?
I like working there.
Yeah,
because they feel like they need to blow
some steam off.
Like they're,
they're kind of wild.
The kind of fun,
you know.
Hey,
as far as
your standup and stuff like you know,
obviously you know where peers you
don't.
And I see you and watch you and stuff
like that.
At what point did,
did your stuff like just really start to
blow up?
Do you know what I mean?
Like really go from clubs because you're
working in clubs,
like I'm working clubs and then all of a
sudden you now you're working like
bigger places.
Like at what point was it about five
years ago?
Four years ago?
Well,
was it the Netflix specials?
Did,
uh,
did theaters in some places.
But um,
it's probably,
mine is all started changing in 2009.
That's when I did a comedy central
special on Spike TV first.
And then the TV and then comedy central.
Yeah.
I started doing bigger places.
Then I started selling out theaters.
Have like 2000 seats in some markets,
but you know,
take me like a few months.
And then um,
then there was the next comedy central
special.
That was another big bump.
Then I was selling out places like the
Belko in Denver,
which is like 5,000.
Wow.
But it takes,
it would take a little longer to sell
out.
But now with the Netflix special changed
everything that Netflix is just a
completely different thing.
Wow.
There's so many people have Netflix,
man I know.
And if you're special,
you know,
and then you,
you really put together something good,
they can say,
oh,
you know,
this guy,
he actually is a real comic.
Really asked actually it's funny,
you know.
And then they want to come see you and
then it's your responsibility to not
fuck them.
Make sure you do a good job and keep
writing new shit.
Constantly keep producing new shit.
Right.
But what does it feel like to be out of
the clubs?
I still do clubs though.
I know that you're in,
you're playing bigger things bigger.
What does that feel like to,
you said Dope.
It's
great.
I mean it's fun and everything.
Like it's a different kind of show
though.
It's like there's more pausing and yes,
it's more theatrical year.
It's a bigger stage moving around more.
There's really good to it.
But um,
I wouldn't say it's better,
it's just different.
It's better financially.
Yeah.
But it's a,
it's just different,
you know,
that must make you feel good.
It feels good.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
Because I played,
I played big places and I've also played
clubs,
but now I'm mostly playing.
I played clubs.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
play all the same clubs.
Yeah.
Like client playing clubs though.
Yes.
It's connected to the people.
It's intimate,
you know?
Yeah.
How often do you turn?
Mm,
I don't know.
I kind of go in spurts,
you know,
I'm working a lot.
I mean I don't work a lot at the store
during the week because I'm like so
exhausted from editing and I edit and
edit all day long and editing.
I'm editing,
I'm well,
I finished the show and crackle that
was,
took a long time,
that show that's on now,
that's on crackle and editing that and
that,
you know,
I spent a lot of time on those videos
and then from there,
um,
I did the documentary Polisher,
stands alone,
which was on showtime and now it's on
Amazon.
That's just the straight doc that came
out a couple of years ago.
I had such a good time filming that,
that I kept shooting in.
The whole thing is about me moving my
mom out of the house,
you know,
out of the big house because when I did
the original docket was just kinda like
kind of skimming the concept of that.
And then I go,
fuck,
I got to start doing that.
So I cut into it.
It's a six part series,
almost like my version of making the
murder,
but I don't kill anyone obviously,
you know,
but it's a six part series based off the
original doc.
So we've been putting that together and
that's fucking dope.
Dude might not know.
So I think we posted second dope.
Your mom's probably one of the most
important,
if not the most important characters
ever in the history of standup comedy,
like her running and owning the comedy
store in the glory days of Kinison and
prior and now today even,
you know,
like she,
she set the stage,
you know,
I mean at all the people that helped me
and like were important to me and my
career.
Your mom was pretty uniquely
significant,
you know,
she,
um,
she created,
you know,
my dad and mom started the place in
[inaudible] 72.
I was four and then it's so crazy.
Yeah.
And then they got divorced.
She won the comedy store in the divorce.
He says he gave it to her,
you know,
there's still like a friction there with
that concept.
I wasn't,
you know,
I don't remember.
I was a fucking four years old and then
my mom became who she really was.
You know,
you're a comic.
I'm a comedy.
That's who we are.
She became a creative kind of force and
she came in at the limelight at a time
where everyone needed someone like that.
You know what I mean?
Like instead of just like a club owner,
you know,
she was creative,
that's why I think part of the reason
why she's sick now is because she's not,
she was never like a real business
business person,
you know,
she's,
she was a woman so it was really hard.
So.
But she was so good at fucking like
Roseanne wear suspenders,
you know,
Gary Shanley put a sweater on,
you know what I mean?
Just different things that she would
help develop.
And that to me is what the store is
missing now.
Do you understand?
There's no mixing.
There's no Mitzi shore there to really
garnish these comments.
I Love Adam to death.
It just fucking doing an awesome job,
but it's not Mitzi shore.
And that to me is something that I think
we have to do.
I think it's our responsibility,
you know,
to kind of give back to younger guys and
maybe spend a little more time there on
a Monday night or something and really
kind of help these kids out and give
them some direction because there is no
direction.
There's no Mitzi shore there.
Um,
so that's who she is,
that's who she was,
that's who she is.
And,
and that to me is what her best quality
quality was when,
when she first met my dad,
it was in the fifties and my dad was a
touring comic and uh,
my dad did a show and a or a summer in a
place called Outcart Lake Wisconsin and
he was doing all summer.
It's like,
that's what you did in the fifties,
you would play there.
The whole,
it was a camp and my mom worked for the
boss of the camp and my mom used to type
my dad's jokes in the back.
Yeah,
she would type the jokes in the back.
No,
this is good,
that's good.
You know.
And she would write it down.
Wow.
And then she would say,
this stunk,
this was good,
that was good.
That's not good.
And then she just developed my help del
Valle,
my dad's act,
they started dating,
they had sex and then my dad took off
and then he was in Toledo,
Ohio and then got a call from my mom
saying I'm pregnant with Scott.
And Scott's just turned 64,
65 years old.
So,
um,
so back then you have a kid whether you
want to or you don't,
you know what I mean?
The abortion thing didn't really exist.
I mean it did,
I'm sure.
But he didn't never wanted a kid and he
never wanted to get married and he never
wanted all of his kids.
He didn't want us.
He just wanted to do what I was doing
what I do,
which was just bang vagina on the road,
have a good time,
you know,
which is which,
which was when my mom,
when I first started,
you know what I mean?
And that got taken from him.
So in his day,
do you ever talk to them about what it
was like to tour back then?
Because it wasn't really comedy clubs
back then,
right?
No,
it was more like a strip club.
Yeah.
Was bars,
bowling alleys,
you know,
places that I play now.
But I had to be a real trip to,
uh,
go from that to being a part of the
original comedy club.
I mean,
other than like the Ice House right now
is the oldest comedy club in the
country.
Um,
but because that's because it started in
like 1960,
but the store was it 72.
So would you say it's incredible.
Really stop and think about that.
How long ago that was?
Before that,
there wasn't really.
Well,
the New York at the Improv in New York,
there was catch a rising star in New
York.
One was that,
that was sort of around that time.
Yeah,
it was a new thing.
Yeah.
So like your mom and your dad?
Well,
my,
my dad,
the way it,
the way it happened was frank
[inaudible] who owns the building,
who owned the building,
said to my dad and his friend Rudy
Deluca said,
Hey Sammy,
you want to start a comedy room?
Because he owned the building where
Ciro's is.
And that whole,
that whole,
that whole building there with the room
right there.
The original room actually,
which was,
which was it?
Which was what it was originally.
And my dad said,
okay,
and then Rudy,
my dad's,
my dad's a writing partner.
Rudy Deluca said,
well,
what do we call it?
You know,
let's do it.
And then my dad was like,
let's call it the Sammy shore room.
Right?
And then he's like,
that's fucking stupid,
you know what I mean,
we're not going to do that.
And then they asked my mom and my mom's
the one that said,
let's call it the comedy store.
So she's the one who came up with the
name.
So they started the comedy store.
My Dad was like the Alcoholic Mc,
you know,
when he was partying,
it was a fucking alcoholic dude.
Big Time.
Like he loved Jmb was his favorite drink
and he would go on stage and um,
he'd bring up Red Fox,
Pat Mccormick,
you know,
um,
Lynn Marie Langston,
you know,
all these guys.
Yeah.
And my mom would work the cover booth,
you know,
we're,
Tommy used to work in that little area
right there.
And she used to give out like,
um,
like little,
peppermints and stuff,
you know,
to the guests that would come in.
And then my dad would go on the road and
open for Elvis and open for um,
Inglebert Humperdink and Sammy Davis and
Sinatra and all these people.
And my mom's always started to take over
the club while he was gone,
like her heart,
you know what I mean?
She,
her,
she put her heart into the club and
that's Kinda where it started.
And they were never happy to begin with.
They were never happy.
So it was time for the divorce.
And then my dad just gave her the club,
gave her the house and took off.
So he wanted to be back on the road yet.
But he's to this day,
he's fucking pissed about it because he
never got a piece of the comedy store.
He never got a piece of the commentator.
And I think that's terrible because he's
the one that fucking started it.
If it wasn't for him,
there would be no comedy story.
If he never had sex with my mom in
Elkhart Lake,
Wisconsin,
there would never be no comedy store
period.
Deep period.
So that's why my dad needs to get more,
in my opinion,
needs to get more credit.
He's,
he doesn't eat,
never gets any credit.
So always or never met him.
I've never met.
Who Does fucking man is the man,
I believe you just fucking awesome.
I'm 90 years old.
Did when you were,
when you were growing up,
did Kennison really babysit you?
That ever really happened?
Because that was always like tell you
who the babysitters were.
Kennison never babysat me.
The babysitters were like lowest
Bromfield Jack Purdue like binder.
August Hamilton,
Mitchell Walters.
I'm ally finder from vsr like binder was
fucking awesome.
Good.
He was awesome.
He used to take me to little league at
the Beverly Hills Park.
Yeah.
And uh,
but Mike Binder,
Mike binders,
fucking.
He was like the one of him and Alan
Bursky were like the youngest guys that
came on the scene.
But Mike Binder,
um,
he used to take me to skate parks and
all that shit because my mom was busy at
the club so she always gave me the
comedians as far as Kennison.
I was a short order cook at the comedy
store in Westwood.
I used to cook for everyone.
There's 200 people there because I was a
good cook because my parents divorced
and I took care of the whole.
I make,
not I,
there's like a menu in my mom's office.
Polly's menu,
not chose hamburgers.
Everything.
I would cook really good and that's
where I first met Sam was 14.
He was like the doorman there.
You were working there as a cook at 14
because I wanted to save up for a
saltwater fish tank because my mom
wouldn't buy me a saltwater fish tank.
Wow.
I wanted to get 100 gallon fish tank
when I came around in [inaudible] 94.
I don't think the Westwood Club was
around now.
When did it?
Does I think 84?
Uh.
Wow.
Yeah,
that's too bad.
I heard that place was wild.
It was like the bastard club.
It was like where everyone,
you know,
like,
I mean our sineal powered regus,
Andrew dice clay.
They would go there and it was like off
the beat.
Yeah.
And then work out there.
And then like the Howie Mendel is would
be in the main room at the store and all
that stuff.
Yeah.
Even back then.
Isn't that crazy?
He was fucking awesome.
It was huge.
Huge.
It's weird seeing him on all these game
shows and stuff like that.
He went up on a comedy store the other
night and I heard someone say,
he does comedy.
I was like,
wow,
that's so weird.
Like people,
they don't even think about it.
You see them on television as a host of
a game show.
You kind of forget that he was this huge
standards before ever.
You did it?
Yeah.
Huge.
Before he used to put a glove or was
hadn't blow it up with his nose.
He would play that little kid that bobby
about.
It was great.
Yeah,
he did.
He actually did a cartoon.
Bobby's world,
right?
Yeah.
I know.
It's a weird.
It's a weird,
like I was at the funny or die thing
last night and I was with will ferrell,
not to drop names,
but I'm a huge fan of him and,
and he owns the site and we were talking
and,
and he just gave it up to me.
He's like,
dude,
you started at all,
you know and see because I used to watch
you on MTV and it seen Amanda.
This generation doesn't know what I did.
Most of the kits,
the 25 and younger,
they don't know that I started at MTV.
They don't know all the films.
They don't know.
They think Sandler,
they think the other guys,
but they don't know that I was the
first.
I was,
you know,
at the time because MTV was so big.
Yeah.
You were the first celebrity you and
like Denis Leary,
like Denis leary became a big celebrity
off mtv two and then like remote control
some movies.
But I was starting in a lot of movies
and I always do albums.
Saw that seven.
I was in my twenties and I was having an
awesome time.
That had to be weird.
It was awesome,
but it's so much growing up like in the
store,
like from the time you were as old as
you could remember being a part of the
comedy store and then all of a sudden
being 20 and being famous on MTV and MTV
was gigantic and I had my own billboard.
It was sick,
it was a kid.
And look,
I had,
I had sold out all the shows at the
roxy,
you know,
I had an album and I was doing all of it
at once.
Was it weird?
It was so much fun.
That's why now when I look back on my
films,
I get kind of sad.
Why?
Because that time of my life was my
happiest time.
Why does it make you sad?
Um,
because it was really amazing and now
life is still good,
but it's not like it was so well.
I think for a lot of people in their
twenties,
at least my opinion when you're in your
if you fuck up,
it doesn't really matter.
And it's in life is like one big,
like whatever.
And that's kind of what I miss now,
like when you get older,
like things are like your mom sick or
this or you know,
there's all these things,
life things,
you know,
or like I'm going to be 50 next year.
You know what I mean?
Just like things like when you're
younger,
dude,
I used to have like me and my friends,
we used to go to the beach and smoke
pot,
you know,
we used to go to the roxy,
we used to go to the rainbow.
It was like,
it was still do that because they don't
feel like it.
We're the ones that make you sad that
you don't feel like doing those things.
What do you feel like doing?
Going to the Korean bath house and
watching the news and chilling and
drinking juice.
We'll just do it.
That's what I do.
So why is that sad?
That's what's confusing.
I wouldn't say it's sad.
I know I talk.
No,
not the movies that watching the movies
make me sad because I missed starring in
films.
So what happened?
Like,
why did that dry up?
Um,
I think it's several reasons.
Number one,
I was so big and I think the bigger you
are and the fast you make it,
the harder you fall.
I think that's just like normal because
it was like you can only,
you know what I mean?
That was one thing and also I think the
whole weasel thing was like,
it was cool for awhile and then like
after a while it's not cool just like a
lot of things and I also think I didn't
listen to my age and some managers they
told me not to do.
I'm in the army now remember I did it.
It was a good movie.
No,
I know,
but here's the story behind it.
What happened was,
is I had a three album deal at Disney.
I hadn't seen,
Oh man,
son in law.
These big hits for me did really well
and then it came time to do my third
movie and it was in the army now and my
managers and the agents were like,
we don't know.
You know,
you have to cut all your hair off and
all that shit in the scripts.
Kind of like,
okay.
And new line approached us with this
other film called totally London,
which is me being an AU pair in London,
which I thought was actually really
funny idea.
And Jeffrey Katzenberg who used to run
Disney wouldn't let me do that movie at
New Line,
you know,
being an AU pair in London.
So he bought the script and shelved it.
So I did in the army now in the army now
didn't do as good as the other films.
And then after that Disney didn't sign
me up to do more movies.
And then after that I did jury duty and
jury duty didn't do so good.
You know what I mean?
So it was financially,
it was when the movies started to draw
maybe poor choices,
like not listening to my agents and
managers and stuff at the time.
But I didn't come at it like,
fuck you.
I came at it like I want to work,
I love acting,
I love going to the set.
That's another thing is like,
I did an Adam Sandler film,
I don't know the,
the,
the uh,
the last one he did the,
I'm Sandy Wexler and you know,
you go up on the set,
you know,
an Adam starring in this film and I'm
not,
you know what I mean?
And I used to star in films and it's,
it's,
it's a weird feeling for me.
I'm like,
I'm happy to be on the set and I love
Adam and he's an old dear friend and I'm
super happy for them,
but I was starring in films,
you know what I mean?
Everywhere I go,
people say,
why aren't you starring in films?
Like,
what?
What's up?
And I can't answer it,
you know what I mean?
Poor choices.
The weasel shit dried up.
Um,
you know,
the movies didn't perform as well.
I didn't listen to my agents.
I wasn't like doing drugs.
It wasn't like I got all fucked up.
I just,
just one movie didn't do so good and the
next one that we didn't do so good and
then they eventually just stopped coming
because he think about it.
Biodome didn't do as good as jury duty
even know now,
like it's a big head,
it's a cold call from me,
but at the time,
you know what I mean.
And Yeah.
And then I got a sitcom on Fox and that
didn't go so things were like in and I
was also turning 30 and I was,
my 30th birthday was very emotional for
me.
I cried a lot my 30th birthday because I
was going from like a boy to a man and I
didn't know how to do it,
you know what I mean?
I was just like,
I didn't know,
like I didn't know how to.
I didn't know how to deal in my 40th
birthday was awesome.
It was great,
you know,
I was happy,
you know what I mean?
My 50th birthday,
I'll probably cry again every 20 years.
Exactly.
But um,
so I missed starring in films,
you know,
I miss it,
I miss it.
I love acting.
That's my first love.
I think,
you know,
I mean you are on fucking TV.
Do you like acting?
Really know.
Yeah,
I mean it's okay.
Can,
you were great on that show.
Yeah,
well I love that show.
I love working with those people,
but I've done some other acting.
I was like,
Eh,
it's okay.
It's not my thing like standup comedy to
me is more fun.
And then hosting you love hosting.
I don't.
I mean I like doing the UFC,
like working for the UFC and doing
standup comedy and doing a commentary
for the UFC.
Those things are fun.
Doing this is fun,
but I'm acting.
To me it was like long hours waiting
around and then also a lot of actors are
cool but there's like 10 percent or just
fake.
They're just weird associate paths they
care about themselves,
their complete narcissists.
They don't have,
I just can't,
I can't connect with them,
you know?
So there was a lot of that because I
think you're a good actor and I think
that
if he maybe developed a show or a film,
you know,
for you,
I think.
Awesome.
That sounds like torture really.
Yeah.
You're saying that I'm like really stuck
on a set.
Yeah.
So you know,
you just don't enjoy it and you just
don't enjoy acting.
One of the things that was appealing
about fear factor was no actors and so
it was like,
oh,
I don't have to act,
but it could still be on TV.
It makes them money.
Okay,
let's do it.
Know,
and I felt like it was going to get
canceled.
I was like,
this is just to be some horrible
disaster and then I'll go have some
jokes about it and I'm like,
I'll definitely get like at least 10
minutes of material at this fucking
show.
Huge hit,
and I ended up doing a hundred and 54 or
something.
You can get,
like,
what is it something you don't get the
same residuals that you would get for a
sitcom though,
but is it called,
what's it called when there's over 100
episodes?
Syndication,
syndication,
money,
syndication.
Money's not what everybody thinks it is.
Syndication might like news radio,
one syndication.
So I got syndication money from that,
but it's not like Jerry Seinfeld
syndication money.
See he owns a piece of the show.
Then you get the real money,
but you get me.
You can't complain.
It's a lot of money.
My friend Peter Lang cough,
he owns Hawaii if I have.
Oh well.
Which is on CBS original one,
but he went over.
He went over 100 episodes.
That's the big payday.
He's fucking,
he's got like a fucking $7,000,000
house in Malibu and he is having a big
old party.
I would imagine as soon as it goes over
100.
You just go.
Yes.
Oh my God.
Right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
you know Kevin James,
a buddy of mine,
he came to Queens,
went over 100.
Oh Wow.
I want it goes over 100.
You long as you don't fuck up.
You're pretty much set long.
You don't go crazy.
You don't start doing math and find
yacht.
Yeah.
So maybe stuff like this will bring you
back to films,
you know,
I miss it,
you know what I mean?
Is it,
you know,
and that side that I was happy that the
Steven Miller thing,
you know,
worked out for me.
You know,
I wonder how,
what would be the strategy to get back
to it?
I guess to kick ass at a comedy special,
be a good way to do it,
to put together a really good comedy,
special loco if you thought about doing
that.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
They have Robbie at Netflix has to hit
me up,
you know,
he's like the guy.
Yeah.
So I mean,
you know,
we're still doing a lot of standup.
Yeah,
I still do a lot of standup or it's
talking about editing earlier.
So another thing that I'm editing,
I'm editing that documentary series,
which I'm happy about it,
but I'm also editing a documentary in my
life and I've been doing that for three
years.
Really?
It's fucking sick.
60 seventies,
eighties,
nineties.
And I've got over 50 interviews.
I got like Jeffrey Katzenberg and oh
wow.
Rotenberg and Doug Herzogg and Chris
Rock.
Mark Marin.
I mean everyone.
Sagat.
Everyone has done it from too,
you know,
comics from the seventies.
Lenny shoultz did it.
Crazy lending,
crazy learning.
So I saw Lenny Shoultz in Montreal in
1992.
Like way back in the day.
I saw him at the comedy works,
the Montreal Comedy Festival.
Yeah,
he's hilarious.
he was great.
He was the original gallagher and a lot
of ways he was,
it was one of the original guys.
He's still around.
Yeah,
lives in Florida.
What does he do these days?
I think he's just retired,
so doesn't have to work the main room he
was as a comic growing up.
He was billy braver when we got,
um,
uh,
as a comic or that he is the one right
above billy.
Click on the
one Arrow right there.
That's one.
Yeah.
So He's,
you know,
his,
his joke,
right?
Which one where he used to do the,
um,
he used to do the lenny shoultz diet.
No,
do you know about that?
Where he would take all his clothes off
and he,
he would do this in the main room.
He would take,
he would take all his clothes off and he
would,
um,
stripped down to a Speedo,
right to a speedo and he would say a
lot.
There's a lot of diets out there and
people don't eat the food they're
supposed to eat or Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
He goes on the Lenny Shoultz Diet.
I put the food on my body of the places
that I want to lose weight.
Right.
So He'd have these fucking pigs in these
ducks behind him and he played the music
and he would have all this food over
there and you have spaghetti and you
know,
and it was just like turned into this
fucking crazy thing and you poor
fucking.
He had poor a cottage cheese in his
balls and then he'd have like great
fruits.
He goes,
if you want to lose some weight in your
elbow,
that motherfucking quite fruits and the
throw the grapefruits you people have
like,
you're not getting.
You have to utilize to see how manic and
like psycho he was on stage.
He got into it,
you know,
I mean,
I'm in,
I would hate to be that type of comment,
especially traveling,
you know,
that's the carrot top is stoked because
he's just stuck in Vegas.
I mean,
imagine if you had to bring a case of
stuff around,
uh,
you know,
we were,
I was just talking to somebody about
that recently.
Those guys don't exist anymore.
Like he used to be a genre,
used to be prompt comics,
but like character there is.
There's letting you guys know.
Yeah,
he was,
he was my favorite comic growing up as a
kid.
Well,
he was.
Yeah,
huge and long island.
All the guys from Long Island loved him.
Yeah.
They loved him.
He was like,
when I first moved there,
I was like,
who's Lenny Shoultz now?
Like you've never seen crazy.
Lenny.
Like he would hold up a bear,
you know,
that uh,
only you the fucking smokey the bear.
And he would,
he would hold it up and go,
only you can prevent forest fires.
Go fuck you punch.
It.
Didn't make any sense,
but you would laugh your ass off.
He'd be like,
why am I laughing at this?
I'm not sure why,
but he was so funny.
There's a,
there's a lot of comics out there that
have it,
that never made it,
that are really funny.
And she ever.
I'm sure you heard of Ali Jo Prater.
Yeah,
sure.
Oh no one knows who he is the best to
me.
He had the best,
strongest,
45 minutes I've ever seen.
Wow.
But he never changed it.
Oh,
you know what I mean?
That happened with a lot of those guys
that never really got mainstream
exposure.
Like know.
Like I remember I went to see Kennison
after his hbo special and he hadn't
quite figured out that you had to have
all new material because the HBO special
had come out and people were yelling out
bits like while he was doing the bits,
you know,
and it's like,
it was that transitionary period because
when the guys would do hbo specials,
there was nothing like that before.
Then where someone had did in the hour
on,
you usually would do it tonight show
you'd be like seven minutes and then you
would go perform.
People actually probably wanted to hear
those seven minutes again.
You know,
who is the most,
to me,
the most prolific comic that always
changed it up with George Carlin.
Sure.
Every year on a new hour.
Every year.
Every year he,
I think at 14,
right?
14 hbo specials.
That's fucking insane.
Saying,
you know,
who else did it?
Richard.
Jeni,
Richard,
Jenny worked at East side comedy club in
Long Island and he did a different show
Friday,
8:00
show different show Friday,
10:00
show different show.
Saturday 8:00
show and a different show.
Saturday 10:00
show.
All the conflicts were sitting around
scratching their head.
I remember I was backstage with.
Okay.
I was an opener back then.
I was just starting out,
but I was backstage with all these guys
who were like local headliners and they
were just like,
fuck,
we're terrible.
It will.
It was just confronted by how good he
was.
Yeah,
he was a fucking G.
I still to this day think that he's one
of the most underrated comedians
ever.
Ever.
Did you ever thing that?
I noticed because we had the same
manager.
Michael Rosenberg was,
was my manager and Jenny's manager at
the time.
The one thing that I noticed about him
though,
if I don't know if you experienced this
with him,
is that his standup in the clubs was
fucking insane,
but for some reason when he was on tv
doing it,
it didn't translate as much for some
reason.
I think the,
uh,
you know how sometimes the camera just
doesn't,
doesn't fit for you.
It doesn't pick up you as funny as you
are.
That was kind of my experience with him
because he was,
you know,
he killed himself and I don't know if
that was part of the reason because he
was frustrated,
you know what I mean?
A lot of people,
I guess they kill themselves if things
don't work out for them.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean like in their career,
I guess.
I don't know.
Well,
he,
um,
he always wanted to be Jim Carrey.
That was his thing,
you know,
he wanted to be Jim Carrey.
He wanted to be the comic that
transitioned from doing standup to these
doing these gigantic movies and he had a
show for awhile and you planted the
platypus.
And he did actually did the mask with
Jim Carrey in that movie.
It was great.
Yeah.
It just didn't get a lot of roles,
didn't get a lot of parts,
but I still maintained that a steaming
pile of me.
If you're listening to this and you
think in like when we watch them,
that you can get it on itunes.
A steaming pile of me is one of my all
time favorite standup specials.
It's fucking great.
It's a lot of it's relevant today
because it's 2007,
but he does this thing about the
difference between people on the left
and people on the right and people in
the middle and it's fucking brilliant.
It's brilliant.
I got to hear that and he was like a guy
that I saw when I was starting out where
I really realized,
uh,
watching him how important it is to
really go in depth on a subject because
he didn't just scratch the surface.
Like when I was an open mic.
Are you.
One of the things you see about open
micros is they'll,
they'll touch a subject and then they
move onto the next subject.
But they basically scratched the surface
of it.
Jenny would dig a trench.
He would go deep and he would like get
everything there was to get out of that
bin.
And then he would move on to another
subject.
And by the time he did,
you were fucking howling and laughter
and holding your sides.
And he was,
it was amazing.
Yeah,
he was,
he was so good.
He was.
Yeah.
He and I agree with you though,
when you see them in the clubs,
you really got to see what it's really
all about.
That's really the problem with like
specials,
right?
It's like trying to figure out how to
translate what you do when it's a Friday
night and the o are,
how do you get someone to experience
that magic of like a perfect club set
and you know,
a special.
I think it's people's faces.
I think it's comedians faces some just
pop off of screen and some don't.
That's my opinion.
There's a little bit of that because
Richard had a weird face and he did it.
He had plastic surgery and there's a
bunch of shit going on.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I'd like clubs too in terms of like
filming because I felt that connection
because when you do your stuff,
you're here in the audience is back
there.
It's a little disconnect if you're in a
big theater.
Yeah,
there's good things about a big theater.
It's like you hear a huge roar,
you get to see the place and everybody's
like,
wow,
pauly shore must be gigantic.
Look at all these fucking people in the
audience,
but when you're at home you're on a
couch or in front of the TV.
It's very intimate so you don't feel
connected to this big giant place.
So that's why my comedy central special
from 2014,
Rocky Mountain High I did in Denver at
the comedy works and the reason why I
did it there,
I was like,
this is an intimate room.
I want to have an intimate show and if
I'm here like this is the place to do
it.
It's like it's nice,
tight.
Let me ask you something.
At what point as a stand up did you feel
that you got really funny?
Like you,
like you felt like,
oh shit.
Like I,
I feel like I'm really funny.
Like you know,
I'd say at the beginning it was more
than 10 years.
In probably 10 years in I felt like I
was competent.
That would feel like I'm better now than
I've ever been before,
but it's just work.
It's just constantly working at it.
Like I feel like standup is one of the
unique things that require.
It requires like rigorous attention and
detail and you have to be paying and you
have to be enthusiastic and you have to
be disciplined.
Like,
and it's almost contrary to what a lot
of us are,
like a lot of us aren't disciplined
people,
which is why we're funding in the first
place because we were silly and then
we're impulsive.
We laugh about things,
joke around about things and think about
things in a fucked up way that's outside
the box of normal thinking,
you know.
So I think that's a lot of times that
sort of mindset is contrary to the
mindset that's required to be
disciplined to right.
But,
but as a kid,
as a kid growing up,
tell me about yours now.
Funny.
Yeah,
that's what I was going to say.
So do you have brothers and sisters?
Sister,
and how old is she compared to you?
She's a year younger.
And then your parents,
you grew up in the house altogether?
Yeah.
Like not divorced.
No.
No,
we were divorced.
My mom got divorced when I was like
five.
Okay.
So that was like me.
Right.
That's good.
Did you have,
did she have a lot of boyfriends?
No.
She hooked up with my Stepdad and
they've been together ever since.
My mom had a lot of boyfriends.
Yeah,
that's different.
Yeah.
But,
but anyways,
you would walk in a room,
a Joe,
Joe Rogan would walk into a room and
you'd say something where they laugh.
Nobody thought it was funny,
but oh,
so no one's a funny person.
Say you weren't funny.
Right.
You know how I got into college and
making people laugh when we were doing
martial arts,
um,
because we're going to fight and
tournament's so we'd all be nervous and
it was like I would be the one that made
everybody laugh,
like when we be on a bus to go to a
tournament.
That's like,
for real.
You talk about this?
Not really.
I mean,
maybe I've brought it up before,
but it's funny.
It's funny,
but it's funny,
just the scene of you on a bus with a
bunch of kids fucking shooting the shit.
Well,
one of them to this day,
I owe a tremendous debt of gratitude to
my friend Steve Graham and my other
friend Ed shorter.
They're,
they're the,
they're the guys who talked me into it.
If it wasn't for them.
And Steve Graham is still a dear friend
to this day.
So you were on the bus,
you're going to your,
you're wrestling tournaments in Boston?
It was kickboxing or talking window back
then,
but yeah,
it would be.
But you grew up right in Boston.
I grew up in Newton,
Newton,
upper falls,
which is like a suburb of Boston.
Is that like by Springfield,
mass?
No,
Newton is like,
um,
it's right off of route nine,
so it's like a natick need in that area.
So it's pretty close to Boston,
you know,
it's like not a,
not a far drive at all.
And I would drive into town to train my
taekwondo schools in Boston and um,
we would travel around the country,
we'd fly to places compete,
you know,
it was like a giant part of my life,
like karate chop shit,
like fucking no tournaments.
So we were always nervous because,
you know,
guys get knocked out,
guys get kicked in.
The face is terrible.
Salary.
You.
I started when I was 15.
That's when I started this as in high
school.
Yeah.
So yeah.
So you're driving to the things.
Yeah.
So by the time I was 21,
like I was like very successful at it.
I was a four time state champion and I
was competing constantly.
I won the US Open.
I won a bunch of these,
like big tournaments,
like the bay state games.
Did you ever go against black guys?
Yeah,
stuff I did.
I was nervous.
I know,
that's what I'm saying.
Fuck right.
Did you be the first black I fought.
I knocked out for that.
That was a huge alleviation of my
worries.
I assume right after I won the UFC stuff
and I watch you out there to like when
you first were doing it,
there was no black guys,
you know what I mean?
I'm thinking I'm just a guy watching it
and I'm like,
where's the fucking black guys?
Because they would kill everyone and now
the son is black guys and they're like,
oh shit.
You know what I mean?
But what's interesting in boxing that
was always the case,
right?
But now you're seeing Russians like
Gennady Golovkin,
you know,
and
like it's,
I mean it's really just a matter of the
economic situation because in the early
days of the 19 hundreds,
it was a lot of Jews because a slapsie
Maxie Rosenbaum and there was a bunch of
Jewish fighters because you know,
there were Jewish immigrants and they
faced a lot of hostility and poverty and
this was a way out.
And then it became Italians like rocky
Marciano,
rocky Graziano.
There was a lot of Italian boxers and
then it became like Puerto Ricans and
blacks and it's mostly,
it's a lot of it is disenfranchised
people that are looking for some sort of
an escape from the south.
So financial keynotes like Kevin Durant
in a way.
I mean playing coop and like,
you know.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean that's their way out.
It's their ticket out of poverty,
you know?
So with Russians now a lot,
you know,
so you're on the bus,
you're with your friends,
you're joking around and expressions of
people do impressions of our friends
having sex,
you know,
that's different things.
So then said,
then one day they said you go to
connect,
go to comedy connection in Boston.
My friend Steve said,
you know,
you're funny,
you're really funny.
And I was like,
look,
I make you laugh because you're my
friend.
I'm like,
other people are gonna think I'm an
asshole.
Because especially in Boston,
which was like really conservative place
and my sense of humor was very fucked up
because these people or a fighters,
you know,
so there was all these black belts who
are competing on a national level
traveling all around the country.
Like they were very intense people so
you could say fucked up things to them
to make them laugh.
Like they,
their,
their borders there,
their boundaries were very different
than the average person because they
were experiencing such like,
I assumed cops would be a lot like that
too.
And maybe even soldiers,
cops I talked to like a lot of cops that
I would train with two,
they had the most fucked up sense of
humor.
Hilarious.
They would be seeing gunshot wounds all
the time and you know,
and there was,
you know,
a lot of jokes they would tell like as
the guy was dead,
you know,
they would be over the guy's body making
jokes when no one was around.
And you know,
people would think it's disrespectful,
but a lot of it is the human brain is
not supposed to experience that kind of
stress that a cop or soldier experiences
and gallows humor as it were,
you know,
that's what a lot of them turn to for
some sort of a relief.
So what I did is I went to an open mic
night and I watched and one,
this is actually a Richard Jeni quote,
it's a great quote.
And he's right.
He said one of the great things about
terrible comedians is they inspire other
people to try it because you watch them,
they go,
well,
this guy is fucking terrible.
We'll lose it.
At least if I suck,
I won't suck that bad.
So my idea of standup is I would go to
someplace and I would see like Robin
Williams and Richard Pryor and all these
people that were just like gods.
And I'd be like,
there's no way I'm going to be able to
go up there and do that.
But when I went to an open mic night,
I realize like,
oh no,
these people,
it's just like being a white belt in
martial arts,
like they're starting from the beginning
and so that's why in this setup for
which club was ditches?
Stitches in Boston and
the eighties,
right?
Eighty eight.
August 27th,
1988.
That's funny.
I started.
My first one was September 25th.
Nineteen 85.
That was my first time.
And the crazy,
just think back all the time.
Just keeps moving on poly.
It's not cool.
It's definitely weird.
Yeah.
It never ends.
It's not going to keep going when you
have a family now.
Yeah.
How many kids?
Three.
Wow.
I know.
It's nuts.
How come here you'd have no desire?
None whatsoever.
Um,
yes,
yes.
But you got to find the right Gal or
guy.
Guy.
You never know.
Right to that.
In this day and age,
you saw an article the other day.
It said a transgender man gave birth to
baby.
And then.
And then Ben Shapiro retweet it.
Woman gave birth,
right?
Yeah.
Just I'm feeling it more now that I'm
getting older because at the bottom line
is,
you know,
I don't want to.
Well,
you know,
Larry King,
Michael Douglas,
Laderman,
these guys have their kids were in their
late sixties way lake.
Well,
yeah.
You know what I mean?
So if you get in like right now,
anyone listening just tweaked their
tweet,
their photos at Joe Rogan and
researches,
it's time to start freezing.
Exactly right.
I should get Whitney cummings pregnant.
What do you think about that?
I'm just talk to her and see if that's
something she'd be interested in.
I would imagine she would not be and she
wouldn't.
Yeah,
I wouldn't want my semen.
I,
you'd have to talk to her to be clear.
I wouldn't want to decide for her or it
could be Eliza.
I think she's getting married yet,
but before.
Ooh,
I dunno.
Why would you want to get the.
But why would you want to get married
now?
Yeah.
I don't know man.
It's like there's pros and cons,
you know,
like a [inaudible],
one of my best friends and he travels
the world and he experiences a life
that's very.
I mean he didn't know what already just
did.
We took three months off actually four
months and just vanished.
Didn't talk to anybody.
Didn't bring a laptop.
Yeah,
he did the Chappelle thing more than
that.
He went to Vietnam and Cambodia and
Cambodia,
Thailand.
We went all over the place,
but he did it by himself with no one and
just met people experience things and
just no one knew who he was.
No,
me and a few people recognized him and
he took pictures with them and put them
on facebook and that's how we found out
he was still alive,
but it was weird,
but he just decided like,
Hey,
I'm just willing to just have an
adventure.
That's something obviously is out of the
question when you have children,
you can't do that.
So there's,
there's,
there's pros.
Not,
I wouldn't want to.
That's not me.
I wouldn't want to disappear for four
months.
No kids or kids.
It's just like I don't have that desire,
but for him,
you know,
the desire to do an adventure,
to go someplace for a couple of weeks is
cool,
but when you have kids,
especially if you have little girls that
wait for you and then they,
you know,
you talked to them on the phone and
can't wait to see you.
It's,
it's a different world,
you know.
How are you now?
I'm almost 50 50 tomorrow.
Oh my God.
Happy Birthday.
Thank you.
That's amazing.
Thank you very much.
Are You doing a big 50th birthday?
Parties are bullshit,
but it's like me.
I went to a friend of mine's birthday
party.
It was his 50th birthday party.
It was so annoying.
They played a video.
We had a watch,
a video and it was like 20 minutes and I
was like,
Jesus Christ.
When is it?
Over?
And then when it was over,
oh,
his fucking family members and his
friends got up and told stories with a
microphone and they held.
Everybody kept up with their shitty
stories.
It was death,
it was death.
I couldn't wait to get out of there,
you know?
It was funny as and play this video I
have here,
you know,
it was weird,
you know.
Did you ever like sometimes like dream
about things like when you think things
like you have dreams.
Yeah,
I knew I was coming in here today and I
had a dream about you.
Yeah.
And it was interesting.
I had a dream that we,
you know,
we were doing our thing and it was cool
and I said congratulations on your new
show.
Your show has been on the air and it was
like,
it was called the Rogan's and it was you
and a camper with your,
your wife and your kids going across
America.
It was like a family,
like almost like,
you know,
almost like the griswolds but the
Rogan's like,
like,
but I know that that's something you
would never do.
But it was funny.
It was hilarious.
It was like on the travel channel and it
was like you guys fishing and eating and
just how hilarious.
It would be.
Kind of hilarious.
But it's kind of gross to because like
whenever I see people that are,
have their kids on these reality shows
like you're not even letting that kid
choose,
right?
You don't even give that kid a choice to
be famous like honey booboo or,
and those fucking people you,
you're just putting your kid on tv
before your kid even understands the
consequences of it.
I mean at least when you got on
television,
you were in your twenties,
like you kind of were an adult.
You kinda got it.
I mean it was young and I'm sure it was
weird to grow up in the spotlight like
that.
But at least you were a grown up.
When you see people that have their
babies on TV and children on TV,
like what the fuck are you doing?
Do you not know as a person's on tv that
this could be like devastating?
Just if they read the comments is if
they went to instagram or youtube and
read the comments like Jesus Christ,
you know,
yeah,
we'll look at child actors do all this.
Do you know what I did recently is a
comicon.
You know what that is,
but you know that like you sign things.
It's hilarious.
It was just sat down one of those
booths.
Yeah.
It was like I'd never done it in a
friend of mine.
My friend of mine in San Antonio hooked
me up with this agent and just,
you know,
they give,
they,
they pay you obviously any fly in and,
and there's basically comicons as you
know,
it's all like,
you know,
people are dressed as superman and
Batman and all these,
but then there's the section with
celebrities.
So there's a lot of like,
people from breaking bad.
There was a lot of people from walking
dead.
But then there was like Rob Schneider
was in a booth,
you know what I mean?
Val kilmer was in a booth and he's got
like throat cancer.
Val kilmer has throat cancer.
Dude,
it's fucking,
it's not cool.
And then you got like Dolph lundgren
there.
I had know Val kilmer throat cancer.
That's.
Oh yeah,
if he's not old,
he's like 45 or something like that or
fuck man.
So it was just,
it was a weird kind of experience.
It was awesome and it was also not
awesome,
dude.
Val kilmer is shit in tombstone.
Was it say spotted with a breathing aid?
Oh,
wow.
Yeah,
it's terrible.
Fuck man.
Yeah,
it's a fucking.
It's terrible.
Well,
he's had some crazy ups and downs with
his weight to the point where you gotta
go like,
Oh,
like look at those pictures of him on
the far right.
Let's look at those pictures.
Wow.
That was in the massive alcoholic days.
I mean,
there's nothing that does that to you
like that other than massive eating and
alcoholism.
That's so sad.
It's weird,
man.
People just abuse the shit out of their
body like that.
What about size road cancer?
What happened to him?
He was,
you know,
look,
let's look at him.
Where's he at?
He was,
he's a friend of mine in the.
I don't know.
He's.
He has used rugged,
some serious drug issues.
Yeah.
He was like,
he's a great actor.
Right?
Fuck off.
I'll tune amazing holiday movies.
He's a savage.
Yeah,
but I saw Michael Madsen there too.
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
I know.
It was like.
Oh,
bummer.
Well you have a good sense
humor about the demise of your film
career.
Yeah,
I've seen you joke around about it on
stage about like,
you know,
trying to get TMZ,
like,
hey
to me man,
I'm over here.
Yeah,
you have to.
Yes.
Yeah,
I think you have to.
And the fact is I still have all my
money.
Yeah.
So I didn't like you didn't go crazy.
No,
no,
it's still in my house.
I don't live in it.
I live in silver lake.
I have an apartment out there which I
enjoy.
I like silver,
like,
but um,
what I like to live in my big mansion up
in the hill.
I to rent it out.
Yeah,
I leased it out.
That's smart.
Yeah.
At least it had to do it.
And I'm,
I'm one person.
Right.
So,
um,
yeah,
that was silver lake.
I like it.
It's pretty cool.
I've never understood silver.
Like it's um,
it's no one bugs you there,
there no tour buses,
there's no billboards,
there's just no starbucks.
There's none of stuff.
It's different than the valley.
It's like all like really cool
restaurants.
Really cool bars.
A really nice people are very quiet,
you know,
you sit,
you can write,
it's very creative.
It reminds the East village in New York.
That's the vibe.
Yeah.
So if you ever go out to the east,
so it's like low speed.
I know bill,
Bill Burr lives in Los Felis and like
that whole area.
It's pretty cool.
And the thing that I really like about
it is the architecture there is still
old Hollywood.
I love the old buildings.
The building that I live in is like in
the 19 twenties.
So it's got that history and I love
that,
you know,
I love that kind of that history.
Like I don't like sunset now.
I drive by sunset.
I kind of like,
you know what I mean?
Like the store and what the Roxy and the
rainbow.
The only places left.
I know,
right?
Isn't aware of when they like when they
chopped down the house of Blues.
It's weird.
The cool thing is the view now,
the view from the stores sick.
Yeah.
But what they're probably going to do is
build something bigger though.
They're going to go to hotel,
they're going to build a high rise.
What do you think about the store in the
future of the store?
You're.
I mean,
you're talking about it.
It's never been doing better than it is
now.
It's amazing how packed it is.
I mean it's sold out every night.
It's constant.
What do you think about the building
itself?
In what way?
Keeping it or not keeping it to
building.
What else would you do?
Well,
I mean I wouldn't do it,
but I'm just saying if someone came in
and offered a whole bunch of money to
knock it down and build a hotel,
dude,
I mean,
what would you think?
Well,
it would suck for comedy for sure,
but the laugh factory is probably not
doing so hot.
Your probably take that motherfucker
over.
Take the laugh factory.
I just moved down the street,
but the room's not that.
That
great.
Have a room.
No,
but you might do something else.
Well,
the thing is the comedy store is
perfect.
That's part of the problem had been.
It literally is perfect for me.
You have three different,
like Wednesday night.
I did the hat trick,
I started out in the belly room.
I'd go Tuesday night.
I started on the belly room,
I did a set in the main room and I did a
set in the.
Oh,
are,
you know,
there's not a place in the country where
you could do that.
Well,
you can perform in front of 90 people,
400 people and 150 people.
I mean,
and every show was sold out to a fucking
Tuesday night man,
Tuesday night,
three sold out shows in Hollywood,
you know,
and for me to work out my material like
it's so invaluable.
You know,
I like to do the Ice House.
I go to the ice house last night,
did like 35 minutes and I did it with
Andrew Santino and Tom Segura and Tom
Papa and frank Castillo and you know,
it's just these killer lineups and you
get awesome shows that people get to
have a great time.
You get to work out and fuck around and
like these,
these clubs around here.
So critical.
There's,
they're so important.
Someone came along and bought the comedy
store.
I mean,
it would be the end of a giant Arrow.
It would be devastating.
What do you think about it?
I think what my mom thinks is leave
alone.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't knock it down.
Well,
who would be responsible?
Who,
who,
uh,
is in charge now.
Well,
I'm not in charge.
So it was it Peter.
Peter.
Yeah.
Well,
the good thing is that the common starts
making money now and a lot of money.
It's doing really well.
Hopefully that's coming around for sure.
My pleasure.
I hope it keeps,
keeps coming and I keep hoping,
I mean,
look,
it's the most iconic comedy club in the
history of that.
I agree.
You know,
it's my heart,
you know what I mean?
It's where I've been my whole life.
I walk into that place every day.
It feel like I'm walking inside of my
mom,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like I really feel like I'm there.
I feel her,
don't you?
Oh yeah.
And it's like,
you know,
the bar in the,
uh,
in the back of the back room,
that bar,
I took it from the Doe Haney House.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
Because that bar was,
was uh,
it was in my mom's house and that's the
bar that can ascend in prior and
everyone got fucked up on.
We sold the house and I was cleaning it
out,
you know,
that's one of the things in the doc
series is I'm like,
keep this bar because it's great.
And then I had one Carlos pick it up and
we brought it over to,
you know,
to Eric in the back,
back room.
And we saved it for you guys are
amazing.
I did that,
you know,
so the comics can have that feeling of
like,
because that bar,
the door Haney house was,
is as iconic as the comedy store.
Yeah.
You know,
because that's the house that was like
the comedy mansion.
But you.
No,
no,
no.
The Doj Haney House.
Which mom said I never went to that,
but I almost bought crust hill.
Okay.
When Chris tells for sale for years
back,
that would've been perfect for you.
That would have a.
The vibe.
It was just I lived there for a while to
living right there.
Yeah.
It was like,
this is just too derelict.
Like I've always been the guy who likes
to live away from stuff and then like
come in and then get some quiet and
peace or like this might be too much to
be like right above the comedy store and
just Lord it might be look at my
burnout,
you know what I mean,
what I'm saying.
But like that room,
it's interesting because that,
that back bar is a new place but it
doesn't feel like a new place.
It feels like probably because of that
bar and also because it's in the store.
Right.
But it's also the old video room.
That's where my mom,
it was like the comedy channel.
That's where she kept all her old video.
So it feels like,
you know that that bar is amazing.
That vibe.
Yeah.
The coolest place you go back then ron
was on his hair around.
It doesn't work for me Bro.
You know what I mean?
That's not cool.
Bro.
Was hilarious.
What's going on in several areas.
He is,
I mean,
it's a great crew there now.
I mean there's so many funny comments.
It's really an amazing time.
It's also like a lot of people like for,
because I've seen the decades
of it,
there's still nothing like the Kennison
and the prior days,
you know,
like I watch everyone in the back and
I'm like they're killing,
but for some reason it just doesn't feel
like I felt
when I was say reasons why?
Because back then they never been
anything like that.
You know,
when you think about prior,
before prior came around,
who the fuck was like prior?
No one,
you know,
and chemists in Kennison was a
completely unique kind of talent.
There's never been anybody like him
before and so now you've seen so much
since then.
They'll never be that uniquely innocent
time where people are like Jesus,
but,
but you know,
to respond to the,
the prior thing when he would,
because I saw him for years,
develop this show there at the store
when he would walk on stage and they
would say,
ladies and gentleman,
Richard Pryor,
it was like fucking Jesus.
It was like people like literally like
with stand up,
no way.
Fuck.
It was like that type of shit.
Like Elvis.
Yeah,
like that type of shit.
So I.
So I saw that in
and there was something.
So obviously he was just so funny.
Dude.
You know what I mean?
Like even if his material wasn't funny
that night,
he was just funny.
There is a genius,
I think a real comedy genius and
probably one of the most influential
standup comedians ever.
Him and Kennison can think kinison.
I mean I think obviously prior was
before my Kennison learned a lot from
prior,
but Kennison was very groundbreaking in
a lot of way.
Like there's never been anybody like
him.
Well yeah.
And it's also before Sam got into too
much of the drugs that he had,
that five year run,
which was fucking insane.
I didn't know I was on that run to with
him,
was opening for him for a while on the
road and then like he started getting,
you know what I mean?
He started going off the.
Yeah,
nobody can sustain that.
Especially.
I mean,
did you ever read his brother's book?
I didn't read.
No,
I didn't scrape book.
And his brother sort of talks about how
Sam just kind of start stop writing
because he was partying all the time and
this material suffered and you could
really feel the difference and nobody
could live that rock and roll crazy drug
life and still be an awesome creative
force.
Like creativity demands your attention.
His um,
I mean I got so many stories with
getting insane.
But the,
um,
his Rodney dangerfield young comedian
specials or like fucking I look at the
second one was just as good as the first
one.
Yup.
You know,
who's a fucking genius dude.
I gotta get out of here unfortunately
today to go beyond.
But I wanted everybody know about it and
so tell people where they could see this
on funny or die.
Yeah.
Just go to funny or die.
Checkout the Steven Miller clip.
Also crackle,
crackle and um,
I'll be coming out with some documentary
stuff.
And Polishers stands alone is on Amazon
right now.
If you haven't seen that.
Pauly
shore on twitter,
which is pauly shore,
instagram,
pauly,
shore,
snap,
pauly,
shore in my space.
A court feldman.
See at the store for sure.
Thank you ladies.
Gentlemen.